okay let's get going again I'm just looking
to get back or two as well
that's okay it's okay I kind of for a while
I think it's a ceiling ice is blocking the
listener
it's okay it's going pretty good
I'm going to the socket still have that
problem
origin
document
that really killed it
it's empty V6 but I don't think that's it I
don't think that's all of it
can buy down
I feel like I wasn't being the best prompt
not doesn't not real mode not in VR mode
which is that I live in
I understand there's no stars no
I don't think we need any of this
control a how would I would never that
control sorry
control e is the screen binding key yeah
screen Vine key if you know about screen
screen as a team Oaks thing right
hey look at it no problems
yep the original before there's mouse that
was screen
and then I was team ox
Define
there's annotation I said the password now
it should actually work now yeah me too I
had to set mine
I had time I'm in muscle memory was like why
would you ever use control 8 whichever Easy
Mac stuff anyway I really don't understand
and we go it's still there
god dammit fucking
why don't you didn't personification for
there
you should never fucking put this in and
password like that too should put in a
password file stupid is totally stupid to do
that even on a container I'm not doing that
it just will not
Indy 500 mg 5 instead of
where is even getting me in D5 from though
you know what you might be onto something in
her I was like Whiting it all the way
there we go
I would send you my vagrant rules now
I think the reason why this because we're
not all I did is I single
doctor Professor how are you
give me a mountaineer IP and I'll tell you
I'll tell you who you are
the most horrific streamer
there's some pretty interesting streamers
little say
how many guests OKC
oh that one let's not talk about him
don't say his name it if it's what I think I
don't want to start a fight again
that's right if it's somebody I've already
had a I picked up that I'm a pretty horrible
for guy to
oh God I'm so sorry Uno reverse
I don't know man
oh I think I do know thatI can oh yeah
oh you okay it with data is on
aaww stock show is on
well you know hey Steve Wolfram is on got
everybody screaming
today's session will from physics project
Stephen Wolfram is streaming have a fucking
dude
oh God that's hard
do do do do
ouch
how's your thing do the thing
read to self proper postgres Authentication
ansible lab
next I'm going to turn this into an ansible
rule
I know it's just an ignorant provision
script I'm back to bigger cuz I got love
bird to work of vagrant
I didn't get it to work chunky got it works
into work and help me out come back to bed
an alias call enable yeah
I do not like exporting password so I'm
going to fix that actually we don't even
need a password
I don't need a password now this is just
temporary I mean if you want to lock down
the permissions later right
around the call this
now I want that I want this to be open
because it's actually inside of the VM
that's
swapping us equals 90 yeah any that anymore
I said I have swap make sure this will just
work
pom pom pom condemn God damn
when you talk about it's just a start
snn Abel plus the Stars humans are a little
bit we are today
hey it worked all right so that's all good
that's very good name of the audio push
press module
to be helpful assistant ctctel and Abel
yeah I know but it's totally fine it's fine
consistency feel
I already know that it has to be at it
because we tried it without it and it
doesn't work
can you enable a stash now you can try to
start without an able and it'll say hasn't
been enabled least in our case you drive
without it
unsee
and give it a test cuz I have it I haven't
said if we can do a test if you want right
now I'm just ready to configuration file
that has me home
I never use an able Edwards you start myself
that they wrote it here and I looked into it
and then they told me about now and that's
the thing
that there is that works
it really is just a between being able to
not being started some
any idea postgres module
package provides a new creation file that is
installed in home
I just if I was installed in the block going
to take the day of his credentials in the
file and there are none available attributes
are explaining idea of law
I don't think we have to do anything to it
not in our little setup are the vagrant
setup
Masked Singer House of Davis
yeah I'm going to do that we can just leave
it because we don't we turned off all of
that Acacia in the database for our purposes
Cedar yeah, why what is it going to do is it
going to help me get this chest test done
has a for sale sign for nothing assassin
Thomas
and I'd rather not go down rabbit holes
right now the nurse provides a new
configuration file that is installed
Hampton Dentistry axles
you need to all available Asher's are
explained in the object chapter
you can enable the iops keep a PS PS we all
featuring configuration files missing it to
the Future
feature enabled that's actually
make sure he's restarted Singapore the
change the effect pictures and name of okay
so that goes in here
that's nice okay alright so
and the connection objects am I
San Diego make sure that
I think it to feature enable I singer
2 future new how to adjust
your arguments I miss your friends at GetGo
that's what their stuff
I sing if you trippin able
I sure miss you too
Exchange Naval idea o p gsum
there nice okay
I see we didn't change anything there's I
don't think we need to do that but whatever
I sing it to you Fisher animal
they're showing me how to use the man page
really on the web it's kind of cute use the
web to look at all your man pages
so
Idaho pgs ql got it
has to be a Suitor command I found out the
hard way
make sure he's stressing you for the change
to take effect Justa resort to singha 2
very nice thank you for paying money to me
because you believed in me I appreciate it
yeah they weren't actually working with no
problem lately
now I did not admit some of that receipt but
then I'm okay I actually know
I know I messed up my best recipe for the
completion and I don't need that anymore as
much anymore
no I do need it still I need a freaking
place I used our crisis Docker images and it
was like beautiful now I know why it was the
first thing listed on the site is because
all the Ruby dependencies would like totally
pain in the ass
aren't we done this
now finally the proper way to install a nice
single web server issues Apache web server I
did that
and that you had several glad we're not
doing that I know we're not we're not doing
it
a Peppa Pig hey you want to
I want to hear you speak I don't know what
that means
if you're trying to tell me that I should
always be caught a cognizant of my audience
on Twitch you're talking to the anti
streamer
2.6 of a scientist
Ivy tables are no rules
Fidos probably do fine save the rest API
I got it is this a
Sarasota County educate users yeah we got it
we got to come back to the recipe of queso
maybe Jo sex
no I don't want to teach the next Bill Gates
absolutely not
yeah kiss girl I think I can't wake or good
we had to go back to the internet stuff
I actually have this is the icing ever post
my setup
and it totally worked is it just a dachshund
to go back and look
icing refrigerate go back and look at except
for nginx
if there is stuff here for nginx I've Been
Told
Charlotte Russe
I have to I'm going to fuck with this let's
check our vagrant file and see if it builds
everything to her you need to right now
made you a full-blown reload destroy
yes how's it going I hope Brut
PSI Home Route we are
we are setting up I single monitoring for
Fun and Profit and testing
and it's bashing Ruby and python it's
whatever
oh that was nice that's super nice
did you tell him thank you
that's actually the first question in the
read me understand what I think is that how
you came to be
like why would you use a single instead oh
that's very nice of you
I just said she just appreciated that you
were helping her learn something you say
thank you that's what you do
I guess you didn't know
I think it's old it's also do 2017 it was
made his support for nagios we use it at
work and I need to talk to the thing that's
the main reason it's here
and because of that what's wrong with her
being 16
I think it's so cool because she was a
university professor and she was sixteen and
she was in your University Hospital and
that's awesome
okay
I don't know is that what you're suggesting
you just spit it out just spit it out
and I don't know why you're telling me this
story I can't read between the lines I'm
dumb
system diseases like come on baby
I got a six-year-old girl bring you flowers
did she think you're hot is that the problem
is that the problem
alright well then you have to make a
decision
all right babe I feel she's consenting
adults I don't know what's the story get to
the point the decision is no it is session
is no there's no decision
all right so what
16 is a consenting adults in the United
States
so is it or is it 18 I should probably
figure that out
yeah I'm pretty sure it's 16
is it 18 shit say I would have been in
trouble
121 it is not
is 18 it is 18/16 and you say no the end
and she doesn't say if she doesn't tell you
she's sixteen and you're screwed it's like
you're like having like a handle
like whatever
well good for you I'm so glad you said no
why she changed her age she said she was
over 18
wow that's some drama right there Celtics
the operation has his file directory
damn we're back to it not work again
I don't know what happened here I was doing
so well
when you come back up here
I'll try again imma try it again
what you say what you say she changed her
age
but officer she told me she was over 18
where you're going to get a real big lesson
and how to deal with that kind of shape
because it's all going to hit the news
because Giselle what the fuck is going to
rat out everybody else besides answering
prince Andrew
there is a credit please run
check that clever I'm keeping well that's
your decision what are you saying she was
like really smart
I thought I was supposed to be charged a
Kuka robotics
we need to get confirmation to students
parents University good idea
another day's gray box is beautiful it is
she can she can tell time turns out she was
a middle-aged tears for she couldn't tell.
Hey if she's if he's hot who cares who cares
depends on your definition of hot
sex is about physics physics physics and
psychology
I don't know I don't know I can't even
change their age
I don't know
ask one of the eternals what a dumbass movie
oh my God it was so fucking stupid
so fucking stupid I can't I feel so bad for
the people that were in it
was horriblewas horrible
I fell asleep in the middle of it and then
my wife told me ending and I was like oh my
God I'm so glad I didn't watch that movie
this is a question you have when you took
when you're a professor of computer science
what how to calculate the age
I'm somebody who seems to be wanting to have
sex with you
it's not a silly question how do you know
they actually want to have sex with you
because it brought you flowers
okay you see too many Hollywood movies
they brought you they show you a fake ID now
we have sex with me is that what happened
this is a wise decision
then what is it we can't figure out your
story is really intriguing though it's
obvious
I thought you were going to do you need some
tutoring with your bubble sort
I got your bubble sort right here
I don't know what this conversation is about
but I got to tell you
oh God
Phil Phil texture operations fuck you and I
change the directory homebaker and I don't
need to
it says initialize it is just fine so I do
not understand
this girl. She says you're such a picture
complete initialize database
I mean maybe
yeah proper when she turned 18 and did you
marry her and have a wonderful life start a
family
that what you did I'm pretty sure I've seen
this movie
has the same girl who played as a singer who
played what's her face
Cruella de Vil
oh God what is this better barter system
holyshit
that's terrifying
we got to watch Stringer Stringer has a big
special thing to talk about today he's going
to reveal something
at like 4 or something I don't know
I know but you would wife that go for it
it isn't getting this plan on just find out
if I get any references I mean I dated
plenty of twenty-somethings I got divorced
and it was
educational and entertaining but
not substantial so I'm so happy I'm with my
wife she's so amazing
city of postgresql no homo it's
can I quote you on that doctor fresch Tracy
since I'm not a bad looking dude honey
I guess how am I ever going to focus with
this entertainment
this entertainment the level of
entertainment is happening right now honey I
didn't talk to you I'm talking to my I was
pretending to speak off-screen to my actual
honey
but I never call honey that's why I was
ironic but in your CB
nice boyfriend agree God
meanwhile what the fuck
this is one of those I forgot I actually am
really grateful for the event because
vaygren is able for me to it really helps me
isolate the problems like and I find that
very very good
nice boyfriend will get it
shit mashitas provisioned
reload
what do you mean can I change a projector
Homemaker I do understand that
I don't think it's fate although honestly
is everything all right
he's probably been drinking they have
probably been drinking again who have I
don't even know ask him it's a man
please work please clap
please clap please clap
it's still doing stuff this is what we do he
put it for Trump
who would not say that out loud
even anonymously
no wonder those young chicks like you it's
it's your Trump supporter earnest
so credit simplink
you know what I don't understand why this is
reported an error is actually not an error
I have a feeling it's just a red output is
wrong coronavirus cure
I just got to cancel you in they are
I don't know I assume to a certain type of
young women who like the way Trump dances
and have neurological disorders bumps on
their back and Wharton unsavory places
we should invent a stream I did already
and that you would invent that stream you
and that testing there's plenty of streams
out there good you go you go you just go
with that
go with that I'm sure it'll be just fine
I would have to be the straight guy which is
unusual for me like as in you know they have
them
now the wacko person and have the straight
guy in the, comedic Duo versus
nice
oh God they all have them I have four kids
all boys that I have hardly zero contact
with now cuz they're all adults and
rolled oats and I got divorced when they
were teens
they're awesome dudes and doing crazy
amazing things with their lives
none of which I can take credit for or what
I haven't even virtual kids
I tried to cancel.
I like you know what you're talkin about I
haven't talked a lot about that those things
I'm actually at work right now but it
doesn't look like it I know most of the
things I have to say I've been sitting in
one or more of those boost videos so that's
that's that's I'm not that's not I'm not
trying to miss you that I've already said it
is written down got to look
yep yeah I think about employment
Friday Friday and Saturday Saturday and
Sunday are dedicated to beginners so all day
Saturday 5 hours every Saturday we do we do
beginner stuff and for at least 3 hours on
Sunday weed we do AMA talk so make sure come
back during this time I do kinda need to
focus on this so I get it running
I feel like this is working now I could be
wrong
it was a tiring I know I was at tiring it
was it was totally boring
I know I have moment Sonata moments go teach
kids in VR
that's so cool I think I knows those kids
when they're they are
can I change my trays to home vagrant
when is the 3-day when you're talking to the
guy I'm with mohawks in Second Life I'll
have you know it's a big fucking deal on the
3D World for like from 2007 until probably
2010 at built I built my own virtual worlds
a lot of money to support virtual
conferences and the edtech retreat I gave
demonstrations to the international Society
for taking education for the use of 3D for
education
I I mean I can go on and on I-90 that stuff
I have that at that train has left the
building I'm kind of I'm kind of interested
to see where this VR stuff goes over cuz
it's kind of bring it back so
diners at the end it was said that we are
nice yeah they're cool
can I change the directory to home
I restarted Singapore this change to take
effect I got did the restore to Singa
Health Annex health education failed
I think I don't think we needed the
personification for that
Arabian white we don't use anymore that's
what was up we don't need that
tell me a singer Abe
that is no longer necessary more time
Universal over the railroads and I'll admit
I'm in reality
go go Have A Nice Class we were only going
to adopt they don't
they don't that's what that was why I
stopped doing it around a business in it
yeah I sold training certification in
education in VR in s life and it just became
really apparent that there is a certain
personality type of after much much
conversations with many many people and
teachers there's a certain type of human who
cannot participate of you there's two things
that stop BR from being assertive serious
solution for education and I hate it say I
hate saying this because I was a huge for
phone number for more than seven years one
of them is at the technology is too heavy
literally too heavy is too heavy to put it
on your face it cost too much to do you
can't have a laptop that
that when we are came out in this the third
time I came out like whenever she will come
out so I can let nothing to him they the two
things I cannot together or mobile so mobile
was really big and all these really really
heavy 3D worlds were a big and they required
a relationship you and a bunch of the stuff
in those two solutions came out the same
time and mobile one mobile one and everybody
left IBM had 50 Sims of which I was a part
of that I was I was helping to maintain and
I ran most mentor to community in IBM for
IBM I was an active you know the doshin turn
on the SD virtual world I created ballet
Simms and art and stuff I got a ton of shit
credit combat systems all of this stuff and
nobody use it I mean they use it then all
the Bandit also use the same okay okay
okay go out Sam can you shut the door thank
you
anyway it says the two things there's it's
too big technology it is schools can't
afford to get a computer with a big big big
ass GPU for everybody that was the first
problem in the second problem is I mean they
barely can afford iPads for the kids let
alone you know computers in a lab within go
use it for education and the second thing is
there's a certain personality type that just
never responds to 3D avatars they're just
never will there it's like the neurology
they just will never ever respond to it so
you can't create a solution that forces
everybody to do then and so it was a two
reasons that virtual servers as an
educational popcorn failed big time and I
can cite the case studies where people with
thousands of dollars millions of dollars
into it and they had to pull it off because
it failed including IBM Honda there's a
hotel if they did some universities
a country called turkey turkey's a nice
country
nice hello welcome very much to be here
thank you for being here seems like
everything work there
they miss a thing already exists their role
is not
exist I don't know if I need a root roll
and if I need a route while actually crit
role
yes I said send you a singer
I mean I could just do a vagrant thing was
just do that instead I see that vagrants
vagrant vagrant
Kratom is a singer SOS singer
owner that's the owner vagrant I single
Dash NTI Singa
take pictures I think it 2 ft radius
licensing at work
assalam assalamualaikum
Nautica Massillon
I was just has to be done it's almost done
now Arabic words
that's not Turkish note I think I think that
they say something close to them
are enabled Theory does not exist federal
return is create database creation filled
I cannot changechange versus you make orange
apparel
I don't know I don't know what all that
means I think we'll probably just changed it
to be
I singer
give me owned by singga
I either errors are getting instead as a
recognized Turkish people say that
Alakazam peace be unto you yeah
and unto you peace interesting yet
paralyzing already exists cannot change
direction Homemaker and created to be a
creation filled or did it just for a
sanitation field freezer a singer
why is a vacation
it should not be using varathane occasion
I'm going to be able to talk to this thing
today or not I don't know we'll see if I can
get it
peace on you
call Charisma Social Security Now on way to
song
I guess you can put that first
peace on every one huh
Pearson Education field pricing at why the
fuck
I think I can disable that actually
I don't care it's all is Rihanna care
BoRics not exist
hey my password has root password on it
I'm just tired of the Earth I'm tired
all right so what's going to sing it going
we got to where do the web server
greatest kind of sayings dangerous Big Data
that's a song
okay if you say so we trust you hey look at
work
so that is a working state how many men
Commit This actually
add Ashley. Hi Gary fohow the fuck Gettin It
commit oh
we do not want that
we do not get rid of cached I figure I keep
forgetting
kids
play some has been deleted I've taken
get ignore fragrance
hey your your your your your status
that was much better committed and read me
and vagrant
up to DB install
get push welcome William boy
wait g h repo creates weight
4th
repo create message Nima
description create Dash D
50 to 2
Amin MD
and if I can work
I mean I can do this instead Ramin ND
pipe two sandwich I normally don't do
Randall s
phone yes Blick
yes
Chase repo View learning learning lab I
think I'm monitoring
stuff Shuffle t h e r o enjoy new Grove
just negro bushing Yu-Gi-Oh this from
another area
then what what
it was stashed you or just made
Blitz and Elmo sings this just makes you a
bad chest my right that's like playing Turbo
DotA
I stomped like crazy yesterday was gonna it
was fun
play Nephew games offline I was play better
right so when we got we got
I heard you said 7:00 they Grant while I
think everything is good status
if I didn't didn't or get at it
let's go open this up and make sure
everything's what we want so here is this
file
is much like Siri can go do if you want to
follow along
I'd say we've got provisions try to answer
them nice
yep thank you it was a great hat
I mean we're getting pretty close to here so
we got down to the play or doing we've got
with an able or features
singer to I think I think this is right
disrespecting I can't so we've got most of
our installation done
and we need to shift gears the web server
now and it does say if you're into Apache go
someplace else so if you use Apache you
might be able to chime in here
free Misty and executed Apache why would you
think so all that shit really
all that stuff has to be installed
why is it why is it previous do you want so
much more involved
where's the best as well as the ring
combination with a piece p a p i n
have you suspended for dancing in it I have
a feeling that the same package to the same
ones we need
FM is optional
is everyone else as a jack stabilizers yes
Mercy
shit I don't think I want to do if you him
I mean it's just for right now right I mean
the Apache install is a little bit
where do you put engine X on here cell
yeah I mean let's just fuck it I just needed
to work fuck it
I don't really care I wanted to just work if
it's using a patch of fun
I would do want to set up at 9 to set up
with the with the nginx
I'm playing the next batch to php7 about you
we don't have to do anything with the Apache
stuff
if I could just knows how to do it how's it
going at the Deadman
please be in genetics nginx is pretty
fucking insane
she's the listing group stuff
Eunice is p s i e s v p i x
we have to follow rules they don't have the
final command
I will do that as soon as you next where's
nginx
I need to know if this is hell
except that she's a convicted oxygen a sound
like yeah I don't care about the rest
honestly don't
I don't use whatever works and I don't want
to change too many variables we could just
cause
so they've chosen patches of primary thing
we're not going to cross the stream organ
he's about you and it's a Memory hog who
cares
but I'm seeing that Jen going to Wild hello
Antonio just lots of old take out there
a survival command
mama mama mama mom let's do it
mg dosage I don't think that there is a
verbal command over here we're going to try
to find out
I miss is actually really good good practice
for lots of reasons
make sure to poke as running superheroes or
yes course
22 Greece money right
now this is a crazed monitoring this is just
general monitoring if you sing a sing a
singer is
a very specific application I don't
recommend it
necessarily I have to test it because it's
it's what we have to talk to at work and so
but this is actually kind of a good
experience with vagrants and reminding me
how to configure a document stuff you know
so I didn't know about the file command for
example as a first-time baby music
Sound Community online womens
Harley-Davidson a voice interface to measure
time from reconfiguration of tank to a
referral do you suffering from experience
means that specified
I'm actually hitting a lot of system into
stuff that I've totally forgotten about or
has evolved since I'm really glad it's it's
annoying but I need to do
letrozole runs time
it could fall songs I have to learn all
about if I walk around at some point
pretending something a list of things to do
sand crane learn
hi how's it going John Key boy do I
appreciate your work yesterday
I've been reusing itI've been reusing it a
lot today
iptables Oye team
you don't normally have to use of tables
usually can use something that's not
iptables what does it say
there is pushing for lady
God damn it's been so long it's been one
week since you met her man murdered to do to
do to do to do to do it really helps thank
you if I could piss somebody off and I said
so I had the time out to like yeah
I don't know why yours didn't work before
our you're too drunk you couldn't figure it
out mine works for just fine and I was like
okay
I'm configured it for $100,000 contracts
into played it alright great
chunky silver found the problem in an hour
we were able to get a gun he's pissed off
man he cannot see whatever they were they
got so pissed off as some people man
they just there you go sis will not you know
I'm sure it was your fault I'm like well
then why is it working now
I I told you that I know you didn't I'm sure
it's going to go look at the logs I don't
give a shit
the only say it because I just want
everybody wanting to know
what how not to behave in it it's really
hard you're going to end up working with
people like that this is not the kind of
people that you want to have in your team
the ones that have to be right and that will
say I told you so or they don't like being
your face seriously in your face I mean God
knows I am that way I am this person myself
many times so it's something that I know I
have to fight as one
we're from the future to some good faith we
all need to do that I don't do it I felt
often and miserably at that platitude I do
not do that I am just as it is it kind of a
sickness in it this really really easy to be
like them out of this works for me on the
way I talk to you you know an end to be
pedantic her to come off as condescending I
do it all the time people hate me people
hate me in the suffering techno dude group
because of it and I acknowledge that it's a
failing and I try to get over it but it but
it's just as well I get reminded what it's
like to be on the other end of it and then I
am like it's nice to have to I don't have
the fucking deal with us
hi Channel. I know it's and I don't matter
even sorry
if I tried I've had to do it at least four
or five times now
you're good people two people that were very
contributing and I was drunk and triggers
for a long time and then they just went on
one of their chariots and they can't cancel
me because I'm the streamer and they can
leave and maybe they'll come back eventually
I've started timing out instead of banning
but everytime I type something out then I'm
going back because that type of personality
does not come back they usually don't and I
get it all the industry fuck I wouldn't
touch you with a ten-foot pole there's no
way there's no way you could give me to go
anywhere near Gainesville on it I'm going to
do it as an indie developer and Beyond to do
it on your own time and have an actual job
someplace else and I think you knew it was
going to work the problem is they work too
much and then I'd appreciate it and they're
not paid for it
go to Cloud native in May trainer thousand a
year and do your game development on the
site for fun
that's what I say
nor does it need more games the world needs
more infrastructure
games are bad if you want to do it underpaid
Hellyeah
has to do with ecstasy I just leave the
conversation happens and if people have
problems is like a distraction cuz those
things is worth the fight I was totally fine
and they said that was using it was great
and they're like and they they said I
honestly have no idea how come this doesn't
work this works for me and I've never had
any problems with it ever
and then I just got pissed cuz I was
frustratedI pissed cuz I was frustrated I've
been spending most of the day working on it
on something else and it was at the end of
the day
I said okay well somebody else had the exact
same problem and they were able to help me
in an hour and he just came unglued came
unglued when I said that
I didn't feel like being nice so
did I say would be was like all great right
I'm happy for you I didn't work for me
though I must be really dumb
it's so and it was like yeah you're all over
the place you're method of testing things
that is completely unscientific it's like
you're not gorgonize and you were drunk
oh you have anything else to add to that in
my stream
it is a laughing now I'm laughing now I'm
laughing this is my new is the 2022 Rob I'm
able to laugh off this kind of stuff because
if I let every single pedantic condescending
asshole who's much like me that's why it
pisses me off come into this room and like
start telling me all the things I'm doing
wrong with my life that are making me unable
to do something else I was just wouldn't do
it
I haven't been in for the role does not need
any more sassy suffer the service you think
well I I probably agree with them
but a boy we got to follow up with that
thank you for that you're in for a wild ride
Okay so
hey look we're at we're doing the iPic
arrested up so I think we're very close cuz
it's exactly what I want I might be able to
talk to the rest API and send messages doing
that
suffer is inconsistent I think is right and
different ways different people how many
software has had plenty of cases where I
went well how did you manage to get it to
the state that it broke that bad but it was
following me looking into how to fix it
while you was doing the same thing and
frankly I don't even think they were being
mean by saying it may have been a little bit
mean before though I've had them say Jesus
just stop typing I didn't type this one like
I had somebody said let me take over the
keyboard and I'm like
that was when I showed him you know Nick
Burns your company's computer guy because
the people that are in this job have no idea
how to help people
most of the time that people who really know
how to do this stuff have no fucking idea
how to communicate and educate another and
they don't want to say just rather talk down
to them or tell him to move and do it for
him I know these people I've dealt with them
I felt like five or six hundred people that
take it from entering the door that way and
and and I'm that way I can just let music
award god dammit that is not how you help me
learn to get through the problem under no I
just tell him to tell me to use this whole
time I was like under no circumstances do
you ever touch the keyboard
at you know because that's what they would
do the chance I want to just let me help you
like you're not going to help them learn it
if you can literally type it for them but
they they get so frustrated by the fact that
they're not picking it up that they would
rather just do it had to be done and that is
not how you help others learn and it's the
one I'm asking for others to help me learn
and help others learn that I can do just let
me do the typing like we don't want to just
sit and watch you fix it we want to hear the
steps to fix it that's why I'm screaming and
it drives people crazy people crazy so just
goes to show really smart amazing people
that make crazy gobs of money are absolutely
horrible at helping other people understand
what they're doing a lot of times and that
this skill of breaking something down into
going through it's simply step-by-step I
believe is in very very underappreciated
skill in the tech world and it's one that I
happened happened to excel at and that's why
I'm here
so
I don't do drugs that have a a command line
break it down when he's doing yeah yeah it's
like okay here's what we're doing here is
why we're doing it this way you know these
are the things that change
I think that's the way to do it and that's
what I aspired to do as long as I don't seem
to just jump through and you know I'm not
interested in explaining everything but but
in general I think that's the best way to do
it really great Engineers are not
necessarily great at sharing and helping
others and don't need to be taken the job
done
so you going to feel like a man blah blah
blah blah blah
I see you going to see how I came and I seen
your face up to anybody have had future I
substitute because as well as the new API is
a goddess interactive thing
I said I got my my patience my spending half
my pay student for mathematical logic and
communicating for sale God yeah I can
imagine I can imagine you have
yeah you're in the show it's got to be so
frustrating for people on the other end of
this to stream to it's like one of those
times when you like a one-way communication
with high-bandwidth towards you and not from
you is really frustrating somebody I've had
people say like this is way too, the best
way to do that by the way it's just say I'm
sorry this is far too complicated to explain
in chat haircut before like typing it trying
to give you a status Rick complex topic I
like don't you don't have to tell me
everything just show me the show me the
links to the resources I can go to the
research you have to spell it out and Chucky
I mean you typing in and ensuring they were
doing the other day was absolutely
astounding because you were just able to
type so much in you know and it would that's
that takes a lot of work and I have all of
these logs you know in my chat history and
go back to you but that's why I spend so
much time documenting the precise things
that you're telling me so that other people
can have it because otherwise it would be
lost to the ether right it's just that the
random people to happen to be here watching
okay I'm going to try to restore deleted on
to find a new pool manager at Grace at fault
again is there a preventative and not that I
know not that I know of a link Gamecast is
live
yeah you want to get yelled down at
I love those guys but they are they are
definitely Lenox get to dudes people you
can't even run the sound like a man to sing
a PSI this interactive I don't want to do
this interactive thing
turn evil the API feature and certificate as
well as an API user use a route without a
password or
in the excommunication file
edit the event filed add the new API is a
project specify the permissions as tribute
shit
I didn't want to do this I might just copy
one over
actually can always post you can always
supposed to last as long as they are going
to get me banned or something
I don't like boobs and shit
latest alkaline I Singa monkey manual
I think we just went through a lot of that
part right in me
yep and then I believe this is the same and
I'm reading right now actually
this is different I see no manufacture
Nation
it's just the filing is generated from a p i
set up I have a feeling it is pictures of
Lena
it's probably what I should have wizards
yeah I couldn't then I see a comes in at 9
logging preferences
action figures I don't know if I want to be
with me I I guess I should see what you
you did that did that we need to love you
though
god dammit guess which direction
all right
Advanced Optics I wouldn't want you Manilow
write me when you got a minute
assembly me if I love you I'm really nice I
might do an API stuff already it's
ABI stuff already it's already got me doing
what female said I know that's a different
thing
Mario I think we want to do I don't think we
actually want to do male I think I think
but this is a good resource for sure
I mean insulation of singer Hip Hop
Minnesota
that's a really good resource thank you
oh it's in there
symbol
I'll be right back
all right
nicest you
everything you wish for Christmas official
resource and they help you puppet Chef if
you have an immediate cessation of single
word to you may want to get to wizard
how do you think yourself is it okay to take
us to me years ago asking if you are using
both stressed that we thought that you had a
chance we can please I sing it to insulation
it's a blessing to web packages do we have
the packages in already
these are my packages right these are this
is how you do the thing restarted sing it to
deactivate configuration
I mean I'm feeling we did most of the stuff
I think we just need to do the rest API now
a song a song a single web 2
say if I sing it to rest API why would you
do the rest of him before installing
let me see if you're not part of the Apache
web server I think it's broken how kind of
weird
it's recipe I have three monitoring core
node really
I tell the rest of you has a different
configuration I sing it's like a single with
two if we can feel the sting of a doctors
for further instructions something if you
did say that I'm using I seen on TV
missing window air condition
are you getting some rest API okay that
makes sense
I don't even know if I needI don't even know
if I need the web then
other than to monitor it right I need to be
able to talk to it to send it messages but I
need to go to see that the messages came in
so I probably need to do the web thing
add ons applications after installation over
you I already went through this salacious of
I saw that this is this is going to be for
the web stuff you have
I see so so I'm not doing I got to do the
API stuff
this isn't this part can be automated
because we got you can run still like him an
API setup
even G no but I had Tennessee
and I looks kind of cool
that is it that was it wait a second
account.
If that's it then we're kind of done
just buy the permissions issue with the name
of mission choir let's go see what it did
I think we can just grab some from Mission
out that we don't need to do anything with
it
UPS condemn it
I see
any occasion I think she's right I guess you
can see if ye already has a root hey look
there's my password
just letting you know I'm sharing it with
y'all I'll let you two have done enough
I I don't think we are going to need the
other stuff I don't know that though
that's a missions we just had to start there
I was just a star
yeah they might open permissions all right
so if we wanted to dial it in we could but
we don't
imma come back to that one in a second
restart a singer
I haven't Steam on my phone
I wish alright so
all right so that's rest API
not not web server
firewall
the says you're not her nose usually is it
yeah
andand we're together faces of the model
call director emerging laundry to sweetie
pie ha
all right I can put it on my list of things
I know I guess
alright so what do we have to do next
my God
huh
I can't comment I usually just wanted to
know the product open-source my friends yes
tell Housewives of folks need a handcrafted
artist such a worry
certified us you think you can work any apps
similar to it now I don't do something
useful that The Bookies was tons of Open
Source projects are out there already
you bring Talent Housewives and the folks
who need a hand crafts that are such a part
of me wants you to play my wife is big into
both of those things by the way had to work
out now. Calm and if if you like that stuff
Instagram so yeah
I want to go check her out
she was she does that kind of stuff a lot
and figuring out how to sell it she's been
trying to set up the store on Wix all day
all weekend and it was a pain in the ass
so now
all right back to the fun times
it's a nice evening isn't it it's been a
nice day today I'm not a very very nice day
I have the most part I can't complain all
right so I didn't get her a CD if I'm all
pieces up I need to figure out some way to
validate this stuff works but I feel like
we're kind of off to webtoon now
which result from the instruction how to
install Tysinger web to if you decide on
using a sling TV
baby what documentation I thought we already
did do that coming over here
alright so
Addison web to see what is the proper pH be
forever forever locations Oh goodie
as fast as possible Festival installation
and can be solved easily from package from
the official package repo setting up his
nose sneezing with my base setup wizard
click here for installation
for wait as long as soon as you see if
there's a package repos I'm all for it I
guess you are a pretty from over to the
singer to please come here we already did
this so it's an automated system described
in the advanced topics
I know you can interrupt at any time that's
where I can meet you here for you can try
the Discord maybe you can get a thread going
on stuff to do and there's a lot of people
are looking for things to make and there are
a lot of things that need to be made and
and the community that you're thinking of is
often under represented by text so I'm all
about it
yeah yeah there's other ways to contribute
for sure
I'm going to help her at your house where
she was going to gracian oh God virtual host
I cannot believe we're back to Virgil's I
used to use those in in 97 for no 96
actually for sale for I set it up or server
our users could buy a virtual server from us
God damn that was a long time ago
oh I haven't seen Apache virtual host files
and so long but went to last time you seen
an Apache virtual host XML file kind of
warms my heart it's like it's like walking
through your old business place if you
haven't been there for 20 years
did I used to live this shit
yeah I I was I wrote a ton of parole that
would automatically configure the stuff and
restart the server so we can have people buy
virtual host from access Internet service
provider 10 years ago shit
God damn it just brings back so many
memories oh my God
Marty Wright member promo I'll be right
there
wow wow
I'm glad I didn't try to cross the stream
tonight is Apache let's just be real here
we're not installing web to from Source bad
idea I know
it's only a single went to
figure Webster I think it's a lie nginx I
thought we were going to be in Jennings
shit wait what is this is automation
we already have Apache installed so
this is her first single with you where's
all the stuff holyshit
we don't want to suffer source I really
don't
roll roll roll roll roll
Timmy fell in the well that this is the link
I'm not going to do it when I get into next
we're not going to I didn't see it is very
nice yes but I don't want to go to that
we're going to take of the patchy it's cuz I
don't want to swim upstream to hear Sam
she's like telling Dorsett Jimmy fell in the
well
or that she has to poop one of the two
we're getting her the hexagon things that
you can put your paws on them and talk it's
hilarious go watch YouTube videos the dogs
they talk by touching them. By touching the
things
so crazy Mana website got no
mannequin Vig
no manual setup phb
kiosk mode with that supposed to be
automated right there
I really hate to I mean to say she was going
to have you go
you want to see the wizard and do things
yourself. Yeah so these are the steps you
need to take some of that you're using my
scope Mario. Remember it's up here to
dependence he's
okie dokie
suck a dick she would it's all fun and games
until the dog starts telling you off right
God damn is a lot of stuffgod dammit
phb has a curl is this the most picture I've
ever done
credit database okie dokie where's the other
crate dangerous thing we already have one
here we go create database call I single web
since remove the fuck button she kept saying
it
cuz they would get mad right
this one, this one time so funny she asked
politely this dog ass politely to do
something
and and they said I'm sorry no at she goes
and she pushes it again really hard and it's
because I'm sorry no we have to wait and
then she goes
You Can Tell She's like okay fine I don't
have it I'm just going to bark at you since
you're not listening to what I'm telling you
cuz I don't want to hear what you have to do
anything she would say she would say wait
know there was one as had to wait no just
say wait no wait no it's just like fighting
fighting with her owner of other things that
she gave up her she just let her have it
I hate my wife just watches those videos for
hours on it and she just sits there and
watches all the dog videos of the dogs
talking back to their owners it's hilarious
it's really funny
alright let's see here what else important
database schema
already I don't want MySQL God no
we're going to report
I'm going to hope that that's there
2222 is there a postgres a pgs you'll
probably
we probably try the Sun I see these pieces
one at a time
Soo-young install
is a red hat system I've worked with in over
10 years
I'm so angry are you angry or you are you
channeling the dogs we talked about
is our let me out or if I take you seriously
I got to tell my wife about that
she will laugh she will laugh out loud
we went walking with her today I single rule
webtoon does not exist
what do you mean oh it's the owner
I single can be the owner
I had it backwards I did it backwards that's
why I'm testing it
yes sir yes sir three I'm an idiot area
he said to us instead of Alma well yeah
Packers offense is going missing right away
that's what everybody says to use I haven't
used it
do you think I was better other than being a
distro named after a Mormon prophet
soso I was wondering not use it just for
that I don't know that that's true
is the alma Linux distribution
named after Mormon prophet
Norman's fuck another text so that would not
scare me I mean I would not surprise me at
all
mlnx distribution
whoever free enterprise grade operating
system Alma means soul in Spanish
okay if you say so
I'm going to let you money then it's more
than that I'm missing money that is more
than that
but I accept their exclamation I take back
what I said
unless I offend any Mormons God knows I
don't want to do that
to do to do having been dormant for 42 years
it's my right to offend them
I paid literally in cash for that right this
is a total guess
Elmo makes music 1:30 Turkish really is it
going to spawn a spawn a lawsuit
this is foul directory fuck you
I I did guess I can't of the day I did I
honestly I did guess
Shih Tzu bring me to can access
this means I think I'm going to has not been
install Ed there is a package yet missing
it's up to read rhel yes security updates I
do remember this as well
like if it's in those bills
yeah unfortunately it is the thing to use in
the everybody hates that they made an
extreme but
I hear what you're saying I sing a web 2
I'm just taking a guess here sudu
Sea-Doo package Army doing yum install
I single web 2
does it exist my guess was right
right so now we have a single at 2 which
minutes
this this is probably going to work now
yes please
got to call that fun redhead install stuff
do you think I was going to stay pretty
stable
honey, yeah
you calling stream stream is is is is the is
the name of you use for ten toes but now it
was the best option for many reasons we have
different use cases and maybe about it yeah
I think it says sorry I just have absolutely
everybody should do that but my question is
do you do you find it's compatible in more
ways than it with redhead stuff
why the fuck is a phone out there
I did the race first thing went to
see my Minnesota phone
a resident login is I see a man man you may
want to see the wizard do it yourself
huh
where is all this shit
I think I did it in the wrong spot
fuck
I had to have them application
my scalp HP
and is looking to put any any any of the
database stuff in here
or missing something or missing something
and is getting is his writing on
I have to have a running a single by the end
of the day or I'm leaving this behind and
I'll just use the docker file
which might be faster anyway this is been an
occasional but I do not wish to do it
further
later how do you install the icing a web
thing
delayed compared to Reddit wow
packages a good yeah I think so rpn
mean
do do do things to do
I wish I had that was I mean does not update
installed package
oh it's already been it's already installed
interesting pulled as a dependency
W drama queen is now I cannot say
I don't think that you needed I think I
think it gets pulled in by the mad at
automatically so I don't I'm not going to do
that
I see will also require pspb at the soc
repository system
there's a measure repossessing it right at 7
to rupture again blockchain
if all the stories is selling package
generating I can pick her up to regenerate
ill-concealed and point-and-click wizard
yeah I try not to go through the wizard
thing so I don't know I guess
release builds I think after this latest we
have this
what time do the wrong thing I think I did
I want to start running in here what did I
do, dammit
yeah only maybe I have UPL release up here
and I didn't mean that I'll get him
cursive Jerry says I think
hey I think I'm overthinking it so I think 7
only spells
the same prebuilds I'm just trying to go
back to the packaged stuff
that's Anarchy this is what we did before
yeah I think I think this is all installed
so
let's go back
a Davis gave him the problem is I can't find
an equivalent Davis gimme for postgres
so that is bothering me
the web server stuff in fact there isn't one
for my she will either
and I'm feeling it's because I sing it
hasn't been properly installed you know I
mean
I think it's because I think it hasn't been
installed I don't
I think a single with two has been installed
so that's why I'm having a hard time I'm
having a hard time finding it and if this is
a chef cookbook so I mean
there's that there's a nice girl to set up
me at that point I'm kind of like I want to
go to the doctor in a while and see what it
does
and I'm and I'm going to do this I'm going
to make a bigger role for the
I'm in this website up stuff I almost don't
even know if I needed but I kind of want to
do that
I mean
I don't know if she's resting group is
already done
Curtis single web to configuration CD I
think I have the conservative figure x-ray
the owner's permission if you want to create
the record manually look up structure
configurations
I don't know it does say it's a dance at the
end of the daySundance at the end of the day
or so if you don't just give me it will fix
this automatically
are you at that you think so all right well
a certain testing a database
manual steps section of the stock and Skip
automated cuz it's the same thing you guys
are girls
well I have to because I wanted whole point
is to make it a bigger thing
I have that already
I think I have it already
I am pretty sure I have already I have it in
my my permission see I don't even know if
it's so far I don't know that it's not
working I'm just trying to find a point when
I was just trying to find this girl here
this part I can definitely do
our house is out for the PS4 that you are
Echo password your top secret password
password to phone
so say up in a misdemeanor automatically
make sure you and I miss you all and you can
I feature is enabling it to it which I
already did I did this already. Patches X
config you did this already
so you could take a picture or some
attention X I think that part sorry that
done too
I actually think that that's doing a bunch
of I already did
has been disconnected Vicki Docker compose
and decompose yes we're going to try it
darker to post next
because I forgot that when I tried talking
to post on Friday converted to cure this
thing and failed last week and I know I do
not make her yesterday because I wanted to
bring up service and ignorant. Just as I
want to be able to bring up I want to be
with you Docker compose and I want to build
a vagrant
so yeah but did you get me closer to my
goals I I need to do that
I mean so it's not answer the web
installation stuff is kind of a pain in the
ass
yeah did you forget I know I need to do
anything I need to be able to do is talk to
the API
that's the only reason I give a shit so so
that's definitely the way to go I'm glad
that people make sure that's the second time
so yeah
all right so let's do
Real Steel
I say that I mean there's just too many
customization Subs here we got I mean I can
come back to it later it's not like you know
it's not like this is I mean if I actually
need to really get into icing I can do
better
strike a pose. Which I put in the thing
there that was just change the settings I'm
going to have some dinner I'm going to come
back looking at you talking to pose because
the goal is to get to talk to it and another
reason to use chakra post I can actually
look at the doctor compose file and I don't
know why I would but I could actually
use everything in the docker compose file
I can already talk to it you think I can
hear you talk to right now
yeah I was only able to text that I have to
like to Corona Post man or something
right now I can act like this is good this
is good I mean this is not a failure right I
just I miss is my first big provisioning so
I'm glad you like me to leave this window
for a bit and come to something else I'm
going to go try that docker-compose for me
to switch gears
let's try let's try to see if that provision
actually totally works with make sure we
don't have any really bad bolts in it that's
probably been like completely are free
has been kind of niceit's been kind of nice
and destroy
if you're all that should I set up a bigger
and I'm really glad that it works now that I
am
I don't like a lot of the old Parts about it
and I'm willing to accept that
latest dog figurines oh you found a vagrant
talk
look at you searching for the right thing
that I didn't look for
I mean why should I not look at that I
should look for that first
that is amazing thank you so much
I think I'm going to even what so I can make
it a separate real
yeah wow
nice very very nice
installing the colonel every time it does
that it takes longer every time
there's an official vagrant box with
everything on it
is it just what is that is that that's just
the web to box right
that's the way to do it
then we can just bring up a web to box and
then but does it have icing on it as well as
it have the rest API on it
God damn that's cool well that's worth
looking at 2
it definitely worth looking at that I can
make my own
all right this is dead she's dead Jim
she said the terminal is dead on your
parents dead are they dead
are they dead hurry or your parents dead I
love that line
opening line of like the last Harry Potter
2nd of August I think actually know it is I
think it's an evil ass
f 911 updates it's got every fucking Nadia's
model
somebody already did all this work
damn damn damn damn search commands for sit
missile attractions
delete a machine folder that was a fail I do
repo demo and test baking stuff
oh my God oh my God
National resource up search for that this is
by the way another reason to use the old and
busted vagrant because there's lots of shit
out there about it going to use forever
it said a package I sent it to
yeah it's got
filter you started seeing a service yeah we
we were added a bunch of stuff that's why I
want to roll it back
Leah L operation
every other from before can I change
register Home Bakery that's ever been fatal
miss you on this is my own I saw that in
there
I still have that stupid ass post wrestling
in there
yeah there's a there's a family but I just
want to hear
this doesn't exist
and it doesn't exist
everything else works yep we'll prove it I'm
going to prove I'm going to prove it
now I'm going to save it and then I'm going
to do so I can post because it's just too
many moving parts
oh I didn't work figuring up see if it comes
up now are we ready
dinner's ready nice taco night Tuesday is
taco night
I have a feeling this is going to work I I
have faith I have faith
oh my God she open the door
why have two tacos now I'm really hungry I
shall return
and when you get out here was see ya
we are going to do knock a really nice thing
to work by the end of the night I swear to
God I'm not going to go to bed
until I can talk to the API
bring me their current gold python or
Postman I need to be able to send a message
to a singer and I need to be able to know
how to do that and I don't have to depend on
the experts at work
cell
I think I was an hour ago that we got it to
work yeah I just wasn't able to actually
says that it's still here and still hear
alternator had it so there's two things
backpacks that you have experience with this
there's two things I need to be able to
check cuz we got the rest API to work right
we need to be able to figure out we need to
be able to test sending a message to a
singer in the simplest possible way so we
can use it as a validation that it's working
that's the number one thing and the next
step from that is to encapsulate that into
something that can be run from within
kubernetes and I will be using any cute for
that so that's already got a thing file plus
mini Cube It's probably plenty as long as we
can get him to talk on the same IP networks
which I think is fine because I think
they're still I think they're all still
inside of the same Data Network so they
should be able to talk to each other without
a problem we can mess with never came later
I single command not found
still didn't do it what did I delete that
doesn't his hair
postgres
it's it's just the other another monitoring
tool there's a bunch of them and they're all
complicated
are you getting that are from
where did he get that are from
sing it sing it, not found I just saw you
feel the install
yeah I went to get it through it's pretty
cool yeah I'll text you the first message
from directory
something didn't install that confirms me
I understand what didn't install feel like
something didn't install
all those Nadia's plugins
I don't know
do that now I want to know what I change
this is why if a cat wasn't created
yeah but that that night has been working
since the very beginning so I'm really
confused
that messed up is not working so again this
is why I look that we can do this
so how it works or see if it works I'm sorry
singer
you know it's just a rest if I delete
something I should know who sing I singer
it's your view just skimming file
this is working before though why is that
not working
this
there was definitely one PSU all file
install that did work the idea of stuff was
working at one point
that stuff was was actually working at one
point
I office is two months out of these two
lines I don't think that stopped it
I'm pretty sure it works
yeah it's probably are right now though I'ma
go eat tacos
yeah
that's another thing I can figure out the
only other thing I messed with was the
package list and it showed me that I hadn't
shifted since my last commit so
I mean let me get luck Aunt Tiff provision
yeah I haven't made any changes to this file
get history they get long it's getting right
what is it I have a shortcut for this I
don't use a remote
that's the only one okay
yeah I think it's fine
I think it's fine all right there so that
you write or something or some other as
girls going on
I think I am not completely sure it's not a
timing thing I guess it wait before
something else finishes you know
cuz sometimes it's like totally green and
others is not it's never taken this long by
the way
I wonder if I'm killing my machine holyshit
God damn I'm glad I came down really fast
got to go to the key moves I got running
I got tons of libert Q is running what the
fuck I like I like hung or something
am I singing leaving or default I'm a senior
center phone
I'll probably stop those hey look we go
again
it is he going to have no idea where to send
let's let's do this okay
send link that was the I know what that
command was
that was this one right here
so that means it's not getting to here yeah
nothing that's not good actually
that's not good because that that's that's
bad that's why
your Service registration over here so you
about the install didn't work
and I'm not sure what
yeah alright well I mean I know I'm this is
a real shot in the dark has a lot of complex
pieces are we we got it working pretty good
so
this enables not working so that's that's
kind of problem I'm from it I'm going to
prove it
she is our person see its provision this was
just a warning. Is there this morning it was
actually up
yeah negron3 load that that provision
graceful shutdown for imports
SSH address say there's a red dress paperie
one what do I do
I live in a cessation of the McLean that's
kind of cool I mean obviously it needs it
he's really all those packages cells
I guess I guess it does reinstall the
packages every time your permission I
shouldn't have to though
that's good to know that because we need
that when you're even afford SS permission
that means it still runs through all the
packaging cells even in they need to be
aware of death checking for something
already exist by chance
it should be inside so it's not a patchy
well we know we had to Indiana choice right
I have the item PS your packages up Saline I
do have that
oh well that works
I act I am now I'm almost positive it was a
timing issue
I'm almost positive I think what happened
was is script
try to go on to the next thing and it did
the other things weren't set up we needed
was some positives and there was something
see it's like restart the Dayman it's
actually all working now so that's good to
know I got to put it a little thing in here
I even a warning in here
fix me there are definitely on timing issues
and this script
sometimes it works sometimes not depending
on delays
excetera so I will come back and fix it
another day
possibly I always want to have an event like
what did I do
yep it was a productive I learned a lot I
missed the first time I've done a bigger
provision of any kind
I realize the whole time you think it's a
thing it actually kind of makes me want to
break down some of the steps in vagrant so
that they when they step completes then do
the next step out of feeling baby does that
and I'm done I'm coming to you right now she
said angrily
I have set unless pissed
bye-bye I think I'll
hello we just found out that our insurance
is not going to cover
the car rental after we got rear-ended my
wife got rear-ended we have to redo the car
and they refused to pay
for the extra days of car rental because
it's taking too long to fix it we have to
pay like five $600 out of her own pocket for
something it's not our fault
God Bless America
that's why my wife is in a in a bad mood she
gets rear-ended could have died
buy a semi on an on-ramp the insurance
pays for us to get a new to get the frame of
the car fixed the frame got tweaked it
wasn't just the it wasn't just the the
bumper was actually the frame got to be so
now we have to pay for I think I'm going out
to people that their insurance is paying for
that but but but their insurance is only
paying for 30 days of car rental and they
haven't fixed the car
and so now we have to wait for another
20 days and we have to choose to have no car
at all when my wife has a higher opening in
Charlotte or we have to pay $25 a day for
car rental
we have no other option
imagine if I was still trying to work for
myself and I didn't have insurance and I was
trying to be a self-employed entrepreneur
why do you think I sold out and went to
Corporate America because you even even
working for a corporate America doing the
the no choice kind of life that American
forces on you working for some big company
that that the 1% of proves up if you still
get fucked you still get fucked
whether you're a student who's got a two
thousand two hundred thousand dollars with a
dead and no job prospects or Yosemite gets
randomly rear end and all the sudden have to
pay $600 out of your own pocket for nothing
that you did that was wrong out of yours
have your own even if you had insurance
maybe we could go to like we do like if we
get the money for him are you going to sue
them for $700 I can pay a lawyer $3,000 to
even get a retainer so I can do the lawsuit
you know the people that fly around at the
upper 1% level at 8.01% into having a care
in the world because I have so much money
and they don't pay any taxes at all and
it's just it's insane it's insanely bad I'm
kind of pissed off in fact I'm done
in fact I'm done playing games I'm done I'm
done going for tonight fuck it you ain't you
at this makes me do this kind of shit that
goes down like this. Does this is why people
turn to Crime I'm not a I'm not saying I'm
going to turn to gripe but this is why they
do turn to crime
this is why people turn to crime and people
turn to Crime because they feel desperate
they feel like they've been cheated by the
system and my my wife actually used to work
in security
erratic Eliza's them
me because they feel like the system is fuck
them over a feel like that they're going to
take it on every visit ended up killing
innocent people I'm not going to do that
don't worry know anybody right but that's
what they need to do because they get that
the system has fuck them over and over and
over and over at they've tried to play by
the system they try to do everything right
they've had to let you know that the 763
credit score of the whole life they've done
all the things that the mainstream World
tells you to do because it benefits the
people in power
until it doesn't and it when they wake up
and get unplugged from The Matrix they're
like what the fuc and then they go Neo on
everybody's ass or they go V4 vagrant you
know
they just they do or they do something more
subtle it's okay fine I'm going to play this
game but I'm going to play it in a way that
no one is going to identify I'm going to be
subtle about it
and that's my choice my choice is DeSoto
away and the subtle way means working for a
big fucking couch he asked company and
playing the game playing the game doing
exactly what they say as much shit is from
them as I can because I ain't they do me
fucking anything and I can go anywhere else
I want to go and I can go work anywhere else
so when there's an opportunity for me to
Robin Hood from the 14 said I do and in my
way and nothing I do is illegal nothing I do
is illegal is all completely within the
boundary of the law working for the company
that I work for just being on their payroll
feels dirty to me because it's so that such
a fucking inflated crazy as celery and I
work hard I work hard I'll give you the
wrong but
the whole system's rigged and email me what
can you imagine trying to be a teacher in
this yet she's being a public school teacher
on 40K a year 46 EK are going through all of
this
my wife could even exist she's an artist you
can even exist without this
the whole system is just totally fucked and
so what happens is you people sorry I was
listening to her rossmanngroup you know him
right
oh so you didn't talk about this last night
at like 2 a.m. I was just like watching and
he's he's down to he's like yeah I put all
these people that played by the covet system
like a I did my thing I close my shop I did
everything I was supposed to and it's not
working and now he's getting kind of
concerned he's like no I'm just going to
open my shop. I want to get covid-19 zhing
so let's write books about hockey capitals
and yeah so I'm trying to say so it's it's
there's many many ways to revolt against the
system it's what I'm trying to say some of
them are more overt some of them involve
playing classical music while you blow up
British Parliament building you know quiet
access like whatever there's all different
layers and and I am not a revolutionary I
have revolutionary my blood for sure
but but I if anything I think it's a
I think you know I always missed her feel
guilty for like like sliding through a stop
sign and I was the guy that like because I
thought I was going to go to hell I
literally thought I was going to go but
didn't follow the letter of the law to those
Mormon I was like hey I have got to press my
break and I have to come to a complete stop
or I am going to all of society's going to
collapse right and it took me I didn't get
to my forties or fifties until I realize
that civil disobedience is the thing civil
disobedience is a thing it's a real thing
it's an ethical thing and and there are lots
of ways to do it I'm waiting for the moment
to launch his Society program
well actually one of them at one of the most
important lessons from from mr. robot and
its Society is that their Revolution was a
massive failure
massive failure that's like probably the
central message of the whole hacker part of
that series is that what they did was a
fucking totally horrible mistake and and
Elliott practically comes out and says what
the right way to do this is it gives you
kind of a recipe and he I can on a play it
and became mean yeah he
when Elliot goes to work for fsociety
because he's going to get money in the US to
figure out how to deal with the inside stuff
he I've said this before a million times he
realizes the secret the secret is to use the
power and energy of of evil Corp against
itself and to change it from within that
means buying into the system that means
being a spy on the inside that means you go
in you you trojan horse that shit you get in
there you know you had access to stuff you
can take down the evil from within and you
don't have to do anything illegal in the
morning.
Being corrupted by the masses
like it like that yeah like at Utica exactly
you just you take you just returned their
energy against them and that that is I
cannot wait to read Hagan capitalism because
that's I think was with the first of that is
Annette that that is the secret the secret
the secret to owning American capitalism in
particular and the backup system that we
lived in is to use all that power against it
by by
buying into it so
the secret I'm going to say it again this is
the hard part is you have to remember I
remember Angela remember Angela mr. robot
Angela is a cautionary tale about what
happens when you try to do this and you fail
because you get sucked into it
so it goes into it and
he's able to keep his his thing together
right there there's a lot of real deep
symbolism that that the episode where they
don't there's like a one taken have this
amazing one take episode of mr. robot it is
so phenomenal one take episode of mr. robot
and there is a moment there where Angela and
Elliot have been separated for a long time
and now it has been an NN Angela has been
like pulled down her path and but eventually
she forced to do things that she doesn't
want to do and she's been removed from your
house she's home in control on and then she
has to face off with Elliot to get her thing
done her hair cuz she has to do done and she
doesn't realize it but she's actually she's
actually still a pain of the whole system
and she's totally being manipulated and
Elliot is still independent because you know
he's The Mastermind
and I'm not going to give the whole thing
away but they're there's this scene when
they come together and I haven't seen each
other for a long time and Angela is the
personification of somebody who went
undercover so to speak it to try to own the
system and got totally railroaded by it she
got sucked into it she doesn't even know
what she's bought into the whole mentality
of it she's decided to think that she's you
know I'll take I'll try the products next I
don't know who you think you're talking to
but I'll try the products next
how do you work for them is this blood on
your shoes how do you work for them I don't
know who you think you're talking to but
I'll try the products next
that's Angela getting totally sucked in and
everybody knows nice shoes right everybody
knows what happened to her that isn't
cautionary tale of what happens when you try
to go in and turn the power against them and
you get sucked into the power the power
takes you over that's what she that's her
story
and I always always story is he goes in
there and he does a bunch of successful
things but then he realizes all the other
stuff is up there that he got wrong and that
he had that he totally fucked up it so now
he has to kind of figure it out you know
cell
it's very interesting stuff i i b b the
secret The Secret of fighting back in my
opinion is unfortunately playing by the
rules
show me playing by the rules you know what
one of the rules is
I have to have a fucking smartphone in this
Society if I don't have a smartphone
I cannot compete
and let's be real I tried this for 2 years I
tried to stay outside of the system I try to
say I don't want to buy into it I want to
have this there's such right I want to be
your toes store Toy Story on it on it on my
own and be outside of the system everything
doesn't work try to do anything without a
smartphone now consider that half the world
how do they do anything
cyberpunk mode absolutely I'm almost there
so you know where's my pet my EpiPen
probably bugged
but you know that's the bottom line is
you have to hack the system you have to in
order to fight against the system and it's
like it's like dormammu
can't even have a drive without a smartphone
I know
it's like this is nobody's asking whether I
should be done or not there nobody is asking
whether we wanted power windows or not I
want to machine it when a car doesn't have
it I don't know if I'll get him
so you know but the thing is you're if
you're going to fight against the system you
have to use the power of the system against
itself the whole door mom with and you know
and that also said there's Marvel Marvel has
that same thing right that that the the
keeper lets her face
Tilda Swinton it whatever it is you know the
one in in where she was going to come out
again right so the timekeeper eye doctor
strange in her secret is that she's using
the dark energy to fight against Dark Energy
the ancient one right like the fakir Library
owner hell yeah it's only did it a I just
think it's an asshole for how we did it is
it ain't going to make a statement that they
never would ever be about he did it but I
don't think you did it well
right so the ancient one yeah
Nation won the message from the ancient one
is she she understood that to fight it you
have to take some of it in and understand it
and use it against itself but you have to
stay pure and the door holder Mama extract
the other people who were hungry for the
power those with the Angelo's so you see
these plotlines a lot all the time it's like
I'm going to take some of the darkness to
fight against the darkness and then that you
have I mean I'm sure my steps I would have a
whole bunch to say about Dark Souls
Dark Souls as you know they're all dead
there are fighting against there's there's a
lot of plot lines that have this in them in
fact including you know a lot of the Star
Wars stuff all the Star Wars stuff
definitely the Battlestar Galactica stuff
Battlestar Galactica there's there's there's
a point at which you know you have to use
the power against it that the tricky part is
is it how do you like gold wielder Lord of
the Rings
I mean come on I would use this power for
good
the reason the reason that they had to
destroy the ring I actually I feel like I
feel like Tolstoy was that's also why I feel
like
I feel like talkin she was by the way a
really staunch Christian yeah he is CS Lewis
used to go on walks and talks about
Christianity he was actually converted c.s.
Lewis to Christianity poking at Oxford
converted is more less c.s. Lewis to
Christianity before they would even run
anything and they would walk around the
grounds and talk about Christianity and
stuff and I think that that's one of the
reasons that there's not a little bit more
subtlety in Lord of the Rings Lord of the
Rings is kind of Dickens tale and dick is
very Christian to write it's very black and
white here either this or that you're either
good or bad to go by there a b c right now
or whenever it's like very but but because
Derek date it was really bad at least did
Jefferson like when when Gandalf says don't
ever offer the ring to me freely I would
seek to use the ring to do good but through
a power but through me it would will the
power so terrible and horrible that
and horrible that they do and it is true
because he would he would take it on and say
Hey I want to take this power and I'm going
to use this power for good
but
u-prep Gandalf the whole world as he magic
can you imagine if Gandalf in fall into the
ring
that's like an alternate ending I want to
see the alternate ending I want to see his
where is where Frodo says no here really
Gandalf take it I don't want it
I got off okay and he takes it and puts it
on and then the rest is like history that
would be so phenomenally awesome I would
love to see that I would I would love to see
that also has some here they do that because
some of the Marvel stuff on Disney they play
around with different timelines I want to
see the Gandalf actually takes the one ring
it's just fine okay I'll go to the store and
you put it on Kenny just can't come back
but you're too much power and so
I don't know it it takes us to a certain
type of person to to be able to use it to
take on the power and be able to not get not
become evil from the power
but I think I feel much less guilt than I
used to before
I was riddled with guilt everyday all the
time when I was Mormon every single little
thing I did I would my my brother I probably
shouldn't say this
I mean I do so anyway my brother's my
brother struggled with it to how about I'll
put that out there much more than I did to
the point where it affected his life because
you think you could just fuck you up a
constructive so bad just living every day
with guilt guilt about this guilt about that
guilt about every law I did and then goes
about being late to a meeting guilt about
not doing my my my church calling the way I
might have needed to you know ironically not
as much guilt about the things I probably
should have felt guilty about like working
too hard or
you know spending time with my family.
Enough of that and I know that it was ironic
because they keep saying her about families
and then they make you so busy I make time
to be with your family
it sound yeah it's a
was Incorruptible even he was on the verge
of failing yeah he almost did he would have
felt like I had the door the Rings about Sam
did you hear from teaching exactly how my
God the guilt over home teaching
you know if your water is still you know
nothing about
we we should have everything. I am talking
too fast I'm sorry I'll talk slower
I'll talk more slowly acting box is saying
I'm talking too fast in Russian
he didn't have any major Ambitions or power
to begin with which it was I think would
help him but still has to be sent here that
evidence for Sam being the true hero the
true protagonist of the whole thing is the
final scene the final scene of the book has
salmon it not Frodo
think about that one for a second that go
read it
the protagonist of Lord of the Rings the
strongest hero in protagonist was actually
Sam
guilt about being opportunistic yeah I mean
guilt about working for a job or I'm making
crazy insane amounts of money compared to
somebody else who definitely deserves the
money more than me for what they do
Society has chosen to Value certain things
but other things and it really weird-ass way
and and you know that can fill out of us who
killed others that we can just accept it
some people actually capitalize on it then I
go hey I'm a female I'm picking up females
here I'm the female women pay for sex I'm
going to sell sex and then it makes sense of
any of that I know people who do this and
I'm at people that I consider respectable
people
very does it some of them have made the
conscious decision to use their body to make
money then conscious decision to do it they
they it's like it's like that's one
particular case I mean there's men who do
this to actually tell one of them to
women pay for sexwomen pay for sex and Men
pay for sex yeah my point is is that
more and more people have realized that the
systems fucked up so they use the system
against itself and they're like I am going
to take the world has decided to reward this
thing I hate the role is done that but I'm
going to make my money in that thing and I'm
going to get out how many how many actresses
I'm picking women here I'm sorry but you
know
it's a thing is it I feel like I feel like a
lot of them were so beaten down Isaac I
would really like to ask my wife about this
was it one of her opinions on this being a
woman and having Grace in it now
my phone is dead you know they're there are
definitely
women who have accepted the fact that the
system is really fucked up and if there's
somebody who wants to Ravel and and
eventually play the system against itself I
can really see that being woman very easily
given what I know about but I've been
sitting with my my wife studying what what
women have been through I don't know why I
could never relate to that but
that you don't want people asking for this
way people who have been really repressed
and really
I think frankly stepped on by a society
they tend to to give you an earlier and then
I can know what
I'm going to be a gold digger I'm going to
be this I'm going to be I'm not going to be
a teacher I'm going to go be a private
instructor I'm not going to be a professor
of mathematics anymore I'm going to go work
for the spin tech company make three times
the money and I'm not going to feel guilty
about it I'm not contributing back to the
world as much who gives a shit because
because they said they start to get greedy
greedy because why because the system is
told him that they don't matter unless they
play by those rules are like fine I'll go
play by the rules I get really big on to get
fuck you money Genesis talk about this all
the time he's the first one who told me
about fucking money I'm going to get fuck
you money then I'm going to go back and I'm
going to fix the system
I need to go back in a minute that donate
all of my time and energy I get a sense that
Striker has fucking money but I don't know
it straight to him right now or is it
supposed to be streaming tonight he's going
to do something to make tonight I really
like Stryker I watch how he helps people
Allianz onto yep plan on starting up
antler Leon to come let you know class of 03
6,000 people
watching Leon right now
weenie is Privateer Pakistani bull mini
answer
when is Privateer significance is the
minimum wage in Minnesota
I don't know if I understand that
I said yeah and you must be at least forty
years yeah yeah that makes sense
and it went as rigorous triggers brilliant
I got nothing to say negative about that at
all especially now that's hacking capitalism
and I think it will fix violence and tell
you it will change yourself oh right right
right we need to drive to the city in your
pocket so many boots women Elsa
I got to remember that one we need Friday to
Vinny's private investor Dania when is
private and how many bullets you mean yes
sir.
Tfue Nas Nasir Nasir Nasir nailo Nasir Nasir
in the city
how can anyone pay attention to get advice
with that many packet without that many
partaking 6K I don't know
I mean you know he has a different format
and and I told you I really I really likely
on his support of his has a much much
different style and I don't think you like
the main thing but I support the motivation
for everything he's doing a really do
understand that some people are saying and
you know if you'd rather be here complaining
about the system in figuring out how to hack
capitalism you're in the right place it
going b key
yeah yeah yeah I just I don't know I
then give an example
if the system says you have to have a piece
of paper from a college accredited college
to get a job then you go to the Community
College or you go to WGU in America you pay
her $67,000 to get the minimum credential
you can get you learn everything you need to
get a job and then you say fuck you system
that's what you do
you don't say it you don't buy into the
system that says you you don't matter unless
you go to college and by the way you have to
go to a good college what's a good college
won with 60% of it in that 60% Legacy which
means people don't even have to take a test
to get in they just get in there because of
their parents and then they may come away
with no debt because their parents are
probably donors of the college those are the
good colleges you fucking kidding me are you
fucking kidding me
there's there anything but the good cards
but you know who goes to work there all the
really talented smart professors because
they make Bank there they get tender and
they make so much money and make the fuck
you money
and he convinced the whole world that that's
the best place to go to school and you don't
matter unless you go to a good school
I got that control but if you need to get
that piece of paper you get it and then you
show him what you're good for you prove it
but this isn't a Docker container which one
do the whole thing
that would be nice if we could do that I
would really like to be able to do that
oh God what is that I'm a little afraid to
look I'm a little afraid to look at that
Arnie pick up Louisiana listcrawler
democracy freezing in action
I wants
50 Cent In Trouble capitalism
that's capitalism I said that's free market
actually to be more precise
that's a nice a good old free market
yeah I know it's kind of horrible is it
yeah
that is an old movie did you know they
almost cast Arnold Schwarzenegger to be
RoboCop
he interviewed I'll let you make it really
made us
they almost they almost cast on
Schwarzenegger to be trouble, did you know
that the actor who played Robocop the actor
who played Robocop was Buckaroo Banzai
Banzai
I didn't know I never made the association
until I watched it I was like oh my God I
know that guy where do I know him from
he was in Buckaroo Banzai if you don't know
my coronavirus eye and you're not American
you need to go watch it
time for the Terminator I know it was at the
same time actually it's around the same time
you have
and James Cameron decorated determine the
Terminator 2 The Terminator and Aliens
almost around the same time
that's pretty crazy
what's Leon saying
Lanza floating head today cuz he's wearing a
green cuz he's wearing a green you seeing
this
Leon's wearing greenLeon's wearing green and
he's got a green screen so he's a floating
head
ghetto Leon is it flooding at today
but it's kind of funny actually
you know people look at my sooner they gave
me the old guy just put the camera on and
they don't know that pain and suffering I
went to have a green screen and look all
properly attired everything and I'm like
fuck that now give me my sweatshirt and I
just turned my camera I don't give a shit
I know
the step certificate to get the four first
as a network administrator graduate
certificate in web development diploma
I don't know I'm not a fan of certificates
at all
meanwhile I'm trying to get ready for three
of them
I I don't know I don't know what that I
would ask the question to I will get your
CNA
it doesn't hurt to look especially if you
don't have other education or experience if
you want to get into operations getting your
CC and a is a fine is a good thing
what time in a college certificate to get my
diploma diploma College certificate
yeah let me I just want to turn on the
stream and go not to look at this and that
and whatever yeah that's exactly what
happened Mouse I mean you remember all that
shit I was doing right and it was hurting my
eyes it was literally giving me headaches I
was getting massive headaches and I don't
feel what I feel, as soon as I get so dark
on my fuck you I don't go out I don't care
okay fine I'll get my mandatory you know
glowing
neon in the back of Anjali but at some point
you like the information and in the content
in the community is way more important than
when I look like or how clean the
presentation is and whether have a cutscene
or whether I have a transition although I
will say this emotes matter and I need a
fact maybe I should work on the boat right
now
emotes matter I was kind of like
you know anti not really anti I was kind of
not into
emotes in those Community Builders from
twitching all that shit and I'm psycho
sisters Arc fuck you if you don't want to do
it and I was wrong I was wrong I actually
really like them I think they are a great
way to build
I think they're getting their good way to
build
to build community and it's fun it's just a
fun thing to do so ice blue it hurts you
absolutely
you have to do the journey to know what you
want absolutely definitely done that a
bachelor's degree if you need a bachelor's
degree there's lots of easier ways to get it
tell me the video card and I think I
actually
a couple of super simple tips to make a can
of you I've been nicer to make you a bit
bolder
text to Lights of yourself I know I know how
to do it I don't need to do it I'm not doing
it
I know you can try to tell me what I need to
do I don't need to right now I don't I mean
I can put a light right here I have all the
waiting I need and Lisa here I just turned
off
my current sent mail so I don't know if you
seen any of the I also did you see they are
all stuff I've been doing like the yoga and
stuff so I my entire thing is on a stick
that it's got a huge cable I can like walk
all over the room and I was going to do that
because I was going to start doing like mac
builds and so I know which I'm still going
to do by the way so more about that I mean I
can zoom in better on my face I could do all
that I don't care it's like I know I know I
really really answered my
I am just over time yeah I kind of want to
play a game while I talk
and play another game if you want to talk I
am I am done with working tonight and today
I worked really hard I worked for more than
5 or 6 hours
and I'm going to have some fun now
and I'm going to do I'll do it tomorrow
we'll do a Docker compose rycenga so
any like find my mother and my eyes are much
better yes
yeah and I have I actually have ambient
light my mother and I have I have a problem
with $500 worth of those strips
got it from Ikea that are all in other color
than young thing that I'll see you
who did Witcher or DotA I have a good winter
I definitely Witcher which is fun too
and where's Witcher but my computer and I am
I just got to change my my title title
I am playing Witcher
Witcher 3 Delta 2232
what is it
now then we can just shoot the shit and talk
I want to play with your Witcher Stephanie
call her cuz I can see what you're saying if
I know which I can't see it
yeah which aisle
kneel before me I see you before me
I do like to wear my headphones on winter
because it's got so much great stereo
I just I just clicked proton and it just
worked
it's one of the reasons I'm selling pop OS
actually
and I don't probably won't leave until until
I know it works
I don't have meant I told you I pop OS red
light therapy I don't know if that's a thing
that actually works
I'm at the turn off this music I think about
which or is it you can't hear it
skip I see you gather before me
terrified to your breasts
letting your babes to your breast
yeah there we go
it's jerking me now
little panel light 1 blue gel 1 Reggio place
in the Halls by minion video broadcast to
add a little DF to the camera the lights in
my eyes at all and I stand out for the
background that was all nice
yeah I know I don't care to do any of that
childcare I do I mean I probably will do it
at some point but
I know I'm just I'm just here yeah I know I
just hate screen it trying to figure out
what you want to change it to
I had to have a w I do not
I thought I had a shortcut key for this yes
no
had to go back and then come back and yeah
here we go here we go
so the loud I know
wait wait wait wait is turn it down just a
bit let me go
chess is also fun nice
and what you do with it is trying yes thank
you
yeah we need to get some of that stuff I'll
get that going on
yeah the witcher's a longtime favorite
it's getting a little louder than when I'm
trying it I'm messing with the sound levels
because I think the sound is so important in
this game I don't want to slide
the venue Arizona. I think yeah
Keira Metz oh hey our first sexual encounter
is coming up
I don't know if I can show boobies right as
long as you're as long as her with your
boobies
it says write it down so
just saying I went by to get upset cuz there
is digital boobies
I see boobies all the time I'm not doesn't
phase me at all my wife is an artist
all right yeah we're going with Keira into
this this this thing here
do I want to put my gloves on do I even have
gloves that's the question do I have gloves
I do and they're not on right now
why am I not wearing the gloves are we go
there you go now you can touch those nasty
things
SM before work I had already
what does free loud and is it too loud
Carlos ghosn
he's sitting right here. My wife said he
thinks she's watching what yesterday and she
said
there's like there's like a mean thing going
to have a Henry Cavill it's like Henry
Cavill English accent in such a such a show
that has Henry Cavill as Superman and
they're like Henry Cavill as The Witcher and
the women are like oh my God
at the Box
the wild Hunt
yeah they they I wonder if that's why I quit
they replaced him
they're replacing Chevy 2
why am I automatically running did I turn
running on automatic larceny
oh shit oh
god dammit who uh-oh drowners
I'm
oh wait wrong I took the wrong sort out
Prince holy shit did I just cut that slack
tide off
I need to eat something I am not playing
very well right now hey sweet bunch of death
I can't I can't remember anything honestly
is your Witcher senses if I Cara
did they replace the view
all right that was too easy my sword is
glowing cuz it's cool
what are we
are they the ones that don't like fire
I'm going to die from drowners I never got
her
I think that I'm trying to make it fun load
most recentcreate a message in WhatsApp
I like I don't like cheating I'm trying to
make it hard drivers usually really easy and
try to make it more fun
because it has been selling for for for a
dress really
well as a master item you see that what the
hell
-6 no sweetie cat
I kind of want to do this with just my fists
I do you guys think I'm lame but
what if I could do it with the torch
area. I'll try this try
where's my Aki
ignorant ignorant
God they don't go down very much for the fun
fist fight god dammit
I don't like that I can't fist fight them I
want to fist fight them it's a crossbow then
Shake Russell then maybe I should rest of
them
22 where are you I know you're there choo
choo choo
are you going to make me come if I go in the
water then I got to shoot him
where's my there it is
are you go
how many volts to have IV infinite
oh shit
god dammit flagging Sears login
you did
all right
this doesn't look so good can I go up please
something I can. Yay
to do to do to do to do to do to do
no
I feel like he's running everywhere why is
he running everywhere that running saved on
or something
it's like he has running on by default I
know you don't have to run everywhere
wait a minute 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2
assembly lagging more than before
hey I know how to do olives
arehard knock that door hard
to do do do do do do
I mean I can do OSHA it I got it
I'm going to die the fickle at 2 god dammit
there's two of them
I need armed to fight this guy
what's the thing that locks them down
I obviously I'm not I'm not into this I know
how to beat you guys I'm just trying to just
going really slow
I am not very good I got a Dodge everything
yard and yeah yeah
weird and whatever
let's go all the way back to the beginning
man alright fine I'll just do it fast I
don't I don't want to waste it though
I mean I could do recipe recipes totally
cheating now
I took cat oil
or whatever Tony well I mean they're still
get search still kind of worship so
we just doing out there there's still one
out there
I should take cat an Indian father's yeah
yeah I can't wait to get acne acne and the
other one right
most of the stuff in here doesn't like acne
poopsie
222 no I don't want to go to there
I can go down there I just don't want to
wait. Olives
how's it going thought you
protect their guts do do do do do do
leather straps that's nice crafting item
hack the Box
I swear we just came from I feel like he's
running a shouldn't be
I think I have permanent running on what do
you think
I don't want to run I just want to walk
I think I did something wrong and I've got
him on front run
I think I actually did something that that
did I think I like a push like em or
something
I'm sorry I don't like running
federal or slaps to smell stuff for us to
get together which one it is
I do I take it when I started I push them an
accident hit me up sometime
kind of s.h.i.e.l.d. magical tree.
To to to to to to Michigan Tech
and I like a meditation I think one of them
tacos I just don't know which one
all right 7 at work
yeah that was it thank you
thank you that was the plan it was control I
had cash on accident I actually don't like
running everywhere
I like walking thank you very much
because I like to have the reason I would
play this game and most of the recent for
this game is to just take in the sights it's
so fucking beautiful just look at this wall
if you just like blowpass this art and don't
look at it I feel sorry for you
yeah I mean it's like so beautiful this game
is so beautiful it's a total work of art
I miss those already I know they're just
like
so much Emmett that's what the whole game is
about I want to I want to take in everything
about it I wanted to know
and I was the same way with World of
Warcraft it took me forever to do stuff or
the warcraft and even OverWatch I'll sit
there during matches and just sit there
forever
yeah I'm going back to where I came from a
pretty sure
this is the light lamps Quest apparently
why blow up my thing
oh hey it's the fog stuff
sometimes I don't feel like fighting
oh shit fuck have fuck you out of nowhere
follow us 15 months ago
holyshit yeah my my streamer versuri was
like 15 months ago
oh my God Mouse that's like forever ago
that's insane my friend that's crazy
I bring it
got that was a mistake it was a blunder
share it
God damn I'm still fighting with nothing
there
that was a close one those Riders to get to
any of them and then I get you they will get
you
you'll never forget you
Islander I attacked the fog I literally
attacked the fog of my torch oh yeah come
here for me to takw you with my torch
what it's the hurt I've done told ya shit
yeah it's insane I know I got it I got to
touch base with my kids I miss them we just
burned up like $600 of the money I was going
to go out and visit my kids with so I'm kind
of pissed after the whole level again
goddamn I need to start I need to be better
save scum
I'm attacked the fire with the fog with my
torch
I can't let him get a hit off cuz they're
they're kind of nasty if they get a hit off
and see if my charger is in the water I need
I need a nice piece of chocolate oh shit was
that
I have a very bad feeling about this
shot him right in the head
all my clothes on
I do need to take a break I didn't you save
I need you to save scum doing this cuz I
have to I'm just too relaxed
it's got it we're missing stuff down there
it's got to be there it is treasure is under
the water are like the best Treasures in all
of Witcher
tell me I'm wrong the underwater stuff is
the best Treasures in all the Witcher
never want to miss one I think I did
hit a dead Runner is the driver
I'm going to die if I don't get back to can
I swim faster apparently not
Shaughnessy Break Stuff stress stress trash
I think you might be right
play finding eternal
and I'm just to chill I don't I don't really
care I actually have more fun with the
you know that I just like walking through it
so I take it this time I'm not rushing it
I'm not I'm like doing everything and paying
like an hour of gwent every time
yeah I don't feel a need
I do have her feel a need to save and
remember how I remember how say game
yes please is is is is a game just like
I said for the hockey for save game I don't
remember it
I got my cave senses on
when is crazy fun I don't like the new
version of it that they did tell you the
truth
I don't I thought I got to two lines
wait how come I can't let you how come I
can't lie to you
Ariel
now but then again I'll go fight the foglets
again I know you're tired of it but
maybe I missed something maybe not why not
walk around the dungeon without my sword
apri stupid
I think so huh
where are they you
God damn it they're going to get me
you're dead
I always knew or me
I'm not cheating I'm not using recipe oh
yeah, at 5
you guys want to talk about is it there's a
there's a
there's a skill you can get that a recipe if
you activated it makes any food you have
last for constantly you just turn it me you
like to eat an apple pie and it lasts for
like 30 minutes of rage and so you don't
ever have to regen during a fight and it
makes fighting way too easy
I saw that my pin is like way way too easy
and I don't have very good armor right now I
I didn't say that I should probably grab
some better armor I like the weather going
to be a little bit hard I like dying
we'll make something work Dark Souls e
already discovered there's nothing in here
right I'm down here
cookie cutter builds yeah
I'm the guy who takes his shirt off to go
swimming yeah I agree
yeah I think that you're right
I think my I got a Braxton I mean my Dodge
is really really out of out of practice my
Dodge is really out of practice
activate I did not start the Cinemax
difficulty this is normal difficulty
but Max difficulty is
I don't I don't want to let any drowners hit
me
oh shit
I got to get ready and then figure out how
to Parry drowner I haven't been able to
Parry drowners you can't you can't Perry's
routers for some reason I don't know why
yeah Hardee's is pretty damn hard onis
pretty damn hard on there for sure
I don't know why you can't you can't very
drowners I've been trying to figure out how
to. Round her for a long time a certain
monsters you can't.
A shit I swear to God there was no stuff
there
I tried to save is it uh oh
that's not it
okay it is at 5 nice
it is kind of like Skyrim ugly or honestly
and I'm going to put my charger back cuz
it's kind of dangerous walk around a fog
with torch out
are humans a Dodge monsters give her a
necklace that that's
is History 2 oh shit
this one was kind of hard to remember right
like we have to find a whole bunch of
symbols
I don't even know if you're going to be here
because it's at this time and it's not part
of this particular Quest
I'm lagging too by the way that light you
see that's also mine
what is that there anything there
I thought there was
pretty dangerous out here music on
baby sink is Anya my music is on right now
for better or worse
I my computer's acting up though I don't
know if you saw that it's like it's really
not happy. I have like multiple virtual
virtual machines running right now I'm
surprised is working at all
yeah I drop at Universal machines off
I don't know just a thought I'm just I'm
just thinking just thinking out loud here
there's actually something over there that
we're supposed to fight I just remember it
let's go up there yeah it's super laggy do
not play with your with like four three
virtual machines running at the same time I
literally have three virtual machines
running right now and I'm trying to run with
you
cuz I'm an idiot
oh I got it Cara or are you Cara but if I
could summon roach over here
meteorite ore
God it's so laggy
oh I'm coming at 5
I can probably just in case I can't see you
when I'm doing
I did say I know it's going to crash
that doesn't sound good you sound like
you're in trouble
you sound like you're in trouble there girl
I have no idea where you are though
I'm coming give me a second deer won't leave
me the fuck alone
what is that mean oh no watch out for those
rats
oh we have to kill the rats nest oh shit I'm
dying
I'm going to die from the rats where is The
Rat's Nest
werecat how are they level five the fuck she
Frets that I can I hit them
yes I do give me a break here for a second
just a second you leave me the fuck alone
all right wait all right wait wait I have to
I have to set up here
all right here we go where is it right here
yay
I already killed it
wait didn't I kill it I do I'm trying to
oh wait there's another one
oh God I'm telling this I am failing a
multiple levels right now cuz I am so chill
where can I hide in there with you honey can
I hide with you why the fuck can I kill this
guy
alright fine I have to back out here again
cuz I'm too tired I don't really want to do
this right now
I just want to eat some food
right right alright I'm out of bombs
how come I can't get acne or it which one is
it I think it is acne
yes and they keep biting me and it's
annoying my and I'm kind of dying
I stop with the fighting
I have to do the thing I don't know what
sign is it kills him
alright fine I don't know
JB I've been trying to give you that if they
keep missing I keep missing in the trailer
if you the stupid ass rat
hair should I try to cross for the rat cure
you're going to be fine if you got that
stupid thing
I can't believe I'm losing to the rats I'm
losing to the rats
at yard and doesn't wrap the rest of them
think I know I know igny
and I know I lost my this was a bomb
honey cable asked me for a long time
all right let's just run in there and get
this done showering
running there and ignore your ass
I don't think that did it
god dammit how come how come he keeps
turning I don't get it
I cannot believe it I cannot turn around
this too much lag
also I suck I'm going to die the rats I'm
telling you
alright fine I have to run away from the
rats you know what I almost feel like
I almost feel like I feel like my my
computer is backwards I'm trying to run away
and it's the key was not doing it it's like
I'm trying to run away and it's not doing it
I'm like literally pushing back right now
and my w is on and I'm not running away
I have no idea what's going on I feel like
it's like a it's like I'm crouching or some
shit like I push something on accident I'm
crashing now
I want to send I could have got put
something on wrong again
I do I think I think make it look I'm not
now nothing's happening
yeah I definitely have sort of some sort of
controller lag look watch
yeah oh hey look a I drink I drink Stout
it's fixed out now I can't see that I'm
drunk
It's time I stopped and put the game down
its rap
this is what I understand is it
something about the movement has changed and
I I don't know what it's like when I when I
broke the running thing
normally I can double tap forward and it
goes fast right it doesn't
it is because I have too much warmer I think
it might because I have too much armor
I sent him I said I said how much stuff
I think I think I think being might because
he would like I think it might actually
no I don't want that I'm not a mind cover
damn I am I encumbered
I think it's I think I'm I think I
definitely have input lag I think it's
what's happening
but did you see how I can't run oh I am or
am I I don't know
yeah I can't run like it how you know it was
on WhatsApp
but I can't run at all right now that's why
I was having trouble
seriously that's a fast as I can go and it's
almost like I'm here watch
yeah this this game fucked up there I guess
now I only run see that now I'm only running
more Stout for me
get nice and drunk maybe I'll fall over I
think I could fall over
I hurry up and my arm is almost dead 2
all right just checking just checking
5 FPS how can you tell
oh yeah I don't know
so first things first
look at that I face right into it and it
went the wrong way
now that looks like it's on fire now
I wasn't even able to dodge before
safire did it yay
he preyed on 550's
yeah it is two controllers I can't 50
strollers even work I know it's crazy
yes
but if yes that's amazing that's awesome
you didn't
can you can you please fix my armor for me
while you're at it I've just blew my whole
armor on the rats for you
hello hello you have something to report
sweat
all right I have to take a break to take a
break bye bye
in my life shopping for cars is she shopping
for cars
hey Kara how's it going girl currently I'm
still I'm still drunk
I probably should but he had a new beamer
are you
I don't know what she's getting why is all
that drunk stuff coming up coming up
I need to get drunk after this
well well what
hey Rob meat yummy think I made me sick
am I actually I'm almost out of food I I
might actually have to put recipe on if this
thing gets bad
got that maybe go for a long time are we
going we're going Cara
what
chilling chilling
yeahfollowing the swallows
oh yeah we were here already
mushrooms I like mushrooms
where is she uh-oh it's a ray
shit can I marry you
how did you refresh your health oh God
what's another race right there
I might need to be drunk for that next time
turn on the salute as it's erased
essence of Rage
new beamer
you say at 5 can.
There it is unbearable and so it's just
common though oh God
Alma Anna sewed I'm going to die from this
did I drink so much bad stuff again I did
didn't I
god dammit
I wish if you took the mushrooms it was like
stop the stuff from coming back and be cool
there's one there's one of the swallows
I wasn't in the water
there is one of the things how come it's not
seeing it
I wear she choo choo choo
what am I supposed to do this weather is it
possible since I did follow the swallow
symbols oh shit
that hurt that hurt real bad
nothing very well I'm going to take a recipe
on cuz I'm really tired right now
where's my recipemy recipe this is cheating
I'm telling you this is cheating
did you see the signs from Siri you need to
use it with her I saw him already
anime
casca say nice I'm still feeling all five
now watch when I drink I like last forever
like last for 30 minutes to see that and
that cheating it's totally cheating I tell
you what
I know this stuff is on the Outer Outer
edges from a run investigated
I never said it updates your igneel lot
better
where are we I can't even tell her I'm at
War I can't I am so tired
I probably should just go to bed 2 2 2 2 2 2
our stuff dried fruits huh
go down here huh I think we are already down
here is the thing
oh my God
I think this is how he got came in I don't
know that though
I hope that's area good
choo choo choo choo choo
I need I need cat what is it in cat School
potion where you can see in the dark
that would be a thing and my keyboard is
like really fucked up
I just registered some commands with the
is a cat's eye
cats are cats awesome
god dammit
where is yard
oh shit
what the hell
play my keyboard is fucking up bad like it's
working so bad
yeah I'm dead I seriously my keyboard is not
doing it just you should see it just
selected all the texts on all of my computer
screens the same time there's something not
right it's worth doing
it why is it loading a whole thingseriously
it's probably time for me to go my wife
wants to talk to me yeah you have another
question
no I'm tired but did you see did you see
that my my keyboard wasn't even it didn't
even it doesn't let me run I had to like
manufacturing also like right now look I'm
pushing forward right now it's not working
it wasn't working it's like seriously like I
have three Vivian's running at the same time
alright I'm going to try to bed and talk to
my wife bye
Escape I need to save sick what
state has been very weird when you mean
inside of Dior
it's not what you mean it's not a local
I agree $6,000 have no issues
certified bubble blah for cars
because reasons I hope you have a nice night
by